Today in history, during the sweltering
Middle East heat of June 28th, 1098,
something happened outside the walls of
Antioch that defied every earthly
calculation, a gaunt, half-dead army of
Christian warriors shattered a massive
and well supplied Muslim force, turning
despair into legend. As discussed in a
previous video, weeks earlier, the
crusaders had achieved a long-awaited
goal, the liberation of Antioch. This
city, once a crown jewel of ancient
Christendom and the birthplace of the
word Christian, was reclaimed by
Christian hands, more specifically arms,
on June 3rd. Yet, there was no time to
celebrate. The Christian victory
triggered a greater danger. Kurbha, the
adabag of Mosul, fell upon them with a
juggernaut. According to sources, as
many as 40,000 Muslims composed of
Turks, Arabs, Egyptians, Persians, and
North Africans. Seeing the famished
crusaders, Kurba scoffed. It is quite
obvious that these people are completely
mad, said he. They are a presumptuous
race. Doubtless they have every
confidence in their courage. But by
Muhammad, it was a bad day for them when
they entered Syrian territory.
The roles reversed overnight. The
besieggers were now the besieged,
trapped inside a half- ruined city,
stripped bare of supplies by its
previous occupiers. Hunger and thirst
racked the crusaders. Some drank horse
blood, others gnawed on leather. Yet
their will remained intact. In the face
of such overwhelming odds, the crusader
leaders convened and chose defiance.
They sent emissaries to the enemy camp
with a message of stark choices. Leave
the city to its rightful owners, that is
Christians, or face the sword. Their
warning struck not only a marshall tone,
but a moral and spiritual one. Speaking
to Kurboga, they said, quote, "What
staggering audacity has possessed you
that you should have marched against the
Christians when you and your king and
your people are guilty of invading
Christian lands with unbridled
covetousness and insulting and killing
them all? If you had any kind of rule of
law, we would negotiate and demonstrate
to you with incontrovertible arguments
what ought to belong to the Christians."
The crusader messengers went on to offer
Kerba something unheard of. If he
embraced Christianity, the city would be
handed over to him and the crusaders
would call him Lord. But if he refused,
quote, "Fly immediately or prepare your
necks for our swords," said the
Christian emissaries.
Kerbogga's fury was volcanic.
Quote, "We took Christian lands by means
of our remarkable strength," he spat.
"From a nation scarcely better than
women." Apparently, he meant the
Byzantines. You are mad to come from the
ends of the earth with insufficient
supplies, too few arms, and too few men.
Not only do we refuse to accept the name
of Christians, but we spit upon it in
disgust. Then came his ultimatum. If the
newcomers renounced Christ and became
Muslims, vast lands beyond Antioch would
be theirs. Refuse, and the Christians,
quote, will undoubtedly die horribly,
said Kerboga. Or endure the exile of
eternal imprisonment. I shall save all
those who are in the flower of youth of
both sexes for the service of my master.
The Christian delegation returned to
Antioch. Their message was received in
silence. The crusaders understood. There
would be no rescue, no negotiation, no
hope unless they forged it themselves. A
fast was proclaimed. The meager rations
left were fed to the horses. Men walked
barefoot through the city, past
shattered walls and bloodstained altars,
praying with bent heads and hollow
stomachs. Everyone was so griefstricken,
wrote Raymond of ugly layers who was
present, that father would not greet son
and brother would not look at brother.
On the morning of June 28th, that is
today's date, they gathered to receive
the Eucharist, a final act of surrender,
not to their enemy, but to their God.
Then 20,000 men, all but 200, left
behind to guard the gates, armed
themselves, formed ranks, and marched
out. Behind them lay a city of bones.
Before them, an army more than twice
their size, fully supplied and waiting.
What followed seemed to witnesses
nothing short of supernatural. Corboga's
army, expecting submission, or at best a
desperate skirmish, was staggered by the
resolve of the crusaders. Ragged knights
advanced like wolves, pierced by arrows,
yet refusing to fall. They bristled like
porcupines. one account says, but still
moved forward, fighting ferociously.
Muslim cavalry, renowned for their fluid
mobility and deadly archery, faltered
before the iron wall of the Christian
advance. When the Muslim horseses fell
or scattered, crusaders seized and
mounted those steeds, leaving their own
starved animals behind. Wave after wave
broke against the crusader line and
fell. The assault turned into a route.
Panic spread through Kova's camp. His
coalition, united by fear more than
faith, disintegrated. The crusaders
bloodied to near death, pursued with an
otherworldly fury. By nightfall, the
impossible had occurred. The Muslims had
fled in total collapse, leaving behind
supplies, weapons, animals, everything
the crusaders lacked and now took.
Chroniclers struggled to explain it.
Many reported visions of angelic
warriors fighting alongside the
crusaders. Whether literal or not,
crusader historian J. Rubenstein sums up
the mystery. He writes, quote, "Modern
military historians have attempted to
come up with a more rational explanation
for the Frank's success, but the task is
difficult. How did a force as spent and
starved as the crusaders managed to
overcome a superior, well-fed, and
well-rested adversary?" "Even Muslim
voices could not hide their dismay."
Quote, "The Muslims were completely
routed without striking a single blow or
firing a single arrow, lamented.
The only Muslims to stand firm were a
detachment of warriors from the Holy
Land. The Franks killed them by the
thousand and stripped their camp of food
and possessions. The Battle of Antioch
became more than a victory. It became a
symbol not just of marshall prowess, but
of spiritual conviction turned into
action. For generations, Christian
warriors would remember the starving
army that dared challenge a giant and
prevailed. And for centuries thereafter,
it was remembered and honored on this
date in history.